[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à tous bienvenue dans
point de vue au sommaire de cette
émission les carburants leurs prix la
grogne qui s'installe et les annonces
des manuels macron ce matin alors des
mesures suffisantes au contraire
dérisoire vous prononcer en répondant à
notre question du jour et nous en
parlons dans un instant sur ce plateau
dans l'actualité aussi évidemment les
élections aux états unis le scrutin
s'est aujourd'hui
mais cette campagne des midterms ce qui
a exacerbé les tensions laissera-t-elle
des traces les deux camps se sont
déchirés jusqu'à un point de non retour
pour la société américaine c'est une
question
nous verrons cela enfin nous parlerons
de asia bibi cette pakistanaise
chrétienne qui vient d'être acquitté
après avoir été condamnée à mort pour
blasphème a quittés mais elle reste en
prison au pakistan la communauté
internationale et en particulier la
france
doivent-elles se mobiliser davantage
pour la faire libérer on va en parler
bonjour leurs habitants merci nous avoir
rejoints d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
vous avez milité au parti socialiste
vous avez été la porte-parole de manuel
valls lors de la primaire en 2011
et aujourd'hui vous avez rejoint lui dis
c'est pas ça non pas totalement non soi
c'est une information c'est erroné alors
c'est celle à rectifier tout ça c'est
les joies du net qui n'est fait
seulement rien à écouter comme étant
dans le contre gouvernement non c'est
pas le borloo avait créé éludé en 2012
et j'avais rejoint lui dis avec borloo
en 2012 et lorsque s'est passé entre les
mains doivent finalement d'accord en
tout cas vous tenez ça c'est sur un blog
oui oui j'écris beaucoup et puis je suis
grande gueule sur et vous êtes grandes
gueules sur rmc
vous avez enfin écrit un ouvrage qui
sait peut-être cette gauche qui nous
désintègre où il est question des
questions d'émigration
bonjour carole barjon bon et aucun chef
du service politique de l'offre
a priori ça c'est bon et vous avez un
peu écarté vous êtes bien peu cartes et
des chants de la politique
en écrivant mais qui sont les assassins
de l'école c'est paru chez robert
laffont 2016
oui aujourd'hui
il est toujours juristes politologues
animateurs de médias police le samedi
sur europe 1 et j'ajoute d'une émission
le jeudi toujours sur europe qui va
faire la naissance de la vème république
en huit épisodes ce qu'ils appellent un
podcast actifs comme les
incompréhensibles avant c'était podcast
relatif ce n'est pas pire d'une série
radiophonique pourparlers avec des
archives pas mal bonjour alexis brisé
directeur des rédactions du figaro
alors on va parler tout de suite de ce
chèque énergie pour que les français
modestes puissent choisir dieu cette
aide pour ceux qui font plus de 30
kilomètres en voiture pour aller
travailler
pas sûr que les mesures annoncées ce
matin par emmanuel macron soit de nature
à calmer les gilet jaune
on va voir tout de suite ce que vous en
pensez mais on écoute d'abord le
président de la république c'était ce
matin sur europe à l'interview avec été
enregistrés hier soir et on écoute tout
de suite
d'abord les gens très modeste pour se
chauffer quand ils peuvent pas changer
de chaudière qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres
options
il faut qu'on regarde là comment
améliorer le chèque énergie parce qu'on
peut pas laisser des gens alors que
l'hiver commence dans une situation où
leur pouvoir d'achat ne leur permet pas
de se chauffer dis donc ça c'est nouveau
et puis l'autre situation que j'entends
ce sont nos concitoyens qui tous les
jours près de la voiture pour aller
travailler
il faut que là on est sur le mode un peu
la philosophie c'est un peu l'indemnité
kilométrique
il faut travailler avec les
collectivités locales les employeurs
intelligemment pour aider ces gens là le
ton du présent volontairement proche des
gens les mesures elles sont à la hauteur
de la grogne
je ne crois pas parce que d'abord je
pense que ça intervient tard c'est à
dire que on a laissé au fond monter un
mouvement depuis maintenant assez
longtemps puisque cette manifestation du
17 novembre a quand même était annoncée
il ya un lit à un moment on sait par
ailleurs qu'il y avait un rien un
problème
en tout cas j'ai ressenti des français
sur leur pouvoir d'achat
malgré ce que peut leur raconter le
gouvernement sur la baisse de la taxe
d'habitation mais qui ne voit pas encore
venir et par ailleurs c'est vrai que
c'est un sujet extrêmement sensible dont
on peut penser que ça prend des
proportions exagérées
parce que c'est vrai que les français
ont peut-être un rapport à la bagnole
particulier en france mais met en tout
cas ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il ya des
français qui ne peuvent pas se passer de
voiture en province pour aller
travailler
donc on a eu je pense qu'il ya peut-être
une sous-estimation de ce mouvement
peut-être qu'on aurait pu s'en saisir un
peu avant et là on a l'impression que on
prend des mesures en catastrophes qui
ont tous l'air un peu d'une usine à gaz
parce qu'au fond on va proposer des
défiscalisations une réduction enfin une
offre d'achat sur sur le sur l'annoncé
elle-même individuel car eux ne faisait
pas vu venir sous-estimé nous sommes
dans une période pourrait même le
maquereau ou quoi qu'il dise et quoi
qu'il fasse c'est trop tôt c'est trop
tard c'est pas assez c'est trop c'est
compliqué ça va être d'ailleurs illustré
sur ce plateau tout le monde va tenir à
peu près les mêmes propos donc pour le
pas en rajouter un quatrième jeu parce
qu on a connu alors alexis vous allez
prendre la défense je sais les shadoks
ce truc on crée des taxes et jasmin en
avant des subventions pour compenser les
taxes c'est absurde il ya comme une
espèce d'absurdité que chacun peut
mesurer et ont fait un discours viril
mal d'efforts écologique
nous avons décidé d'eux et ça bougera
pas et on changera pas parce que il faut
le bien de la planète l'exigent et puis
après on finit par dire euh bah c'est
pas nous excuser moi mais c'est pas moi
c'est pas bibi les carburants s'est pas
bible illustre ce que j'avais à dire
c'est à dire si mal qu'on n'avait rien
dit il est vraiment pas à l'écouté des
français il n'entend pas il ne les prend
pas qu'il ya des gens et les deux sens
quelque chose de blanc c'est vrai il
aura en son honneur il en tombe à
écouter à temps c'est parce qu'il n'a
rien entendu qui l'obligeait à procéder
à ces contorsions absurde où il vient de
dire à la radio
j'aime la voiture on lui demande pas
s'il est là c'est vraiment l'analyse de
la banalité du macumba sur twitter
attendez vous mais vous trouvez que
c'est intéressant dire j'aime les
voitures les gens se disent mais il a
mené l'iddac ensemble il est loin des
français et encore on ne comprend pas
les fruits face à l'écossé les français
mais s'est estimé témoigné le respect
qu'on doit aux français en disant moi je
suis comme vous j'aime la bagnole duo
finlandais sont pas si ni l'un ni
l'autre est en train de discuter dans
une déambulation dans une balle a alors
eu l'idée en face à nikos aliagas et moi
j'aime la bagnole annoncé l'ajout rapide
dans votre tour c'est la bagnole il faut
pas y toucher
non mais je crois qu'il ya quelque chose
d'un dénia bleus on peut pas tout
imputer à maquereau mais ont pu lui
imputer un certain nombre de choses
c'est que la grogne des français elle
est réelle c'est une addition une
superposition d'éléments factuels qui
sont l'addition dans le porte monnaie
qui son pouvoir d'achat
maintenant quand il parle de solutions
de chèques énergie descendre communal le
communaux d'action sociale dont dans
lesquels je travaille délivre chaque
année des chèques énergie aux gens qui
ont un quotient qui leur permet de
bénéficier de cela
donc ils inventent quelque part une
espèce de sorties de secours pour
quelque chose pour une grogne qui
finalement maladie cnam et or plus il ay
la kali elle est légère et légitime la
grogne c'est évident il dit je ne veux
pas taxer le travail mais quand votre
voiture c'est votre outil de travail
forcément vous le taxer c'est
obligatoire mais j'entends bien mais il
n'a pas les chèques énergie il a dit sur
les chèques énergie si j'ai bien entendu
qu'il fallait en faire davantage
vous vous dites ça existe déjà a juste
avant alexis ajinça dallas de rien du
tout donc votre truc qui existe c'est
une usine à gaz
non non à ceux qui adorent
je veux dire c'est que il il sort des
jokers qui existe déjà
donc ça veut dire que il c'est à dire
que la grogne pour la calmer il sort des
dispositifs qui existent déjà
donc ça c'est pas important ce qui est
important c'est qu'il avoue par par v
hier par la surenchère de propositions
qu'il est qu'il est en train de faire
que c'est vrai que cette taxe des
carburants plombe le panier des gens
l'entente il entend bien sûr mais
entendre c'est pas suffisant
c'est ça fait 18 mois de gouvernement ou
quand même ça a été quand même empreint
de un comportement à l'égard des
français que voilà ça laisse des traces
donc maintenant ils rament
ils rament pour revivre 2000 est devenu
la cible ça donne envie de défendre mme
bacon qui m'était pas arrivé depuis
longtemps donc vous avez alexis vous
aviez vous disiez à olivier
non ce turbo et notamment le par exemple
le chèque du sénat mais là c'est vrai
que les républicains ont proposé aussi
quelque chose qui était no mercy que
j'ai la trouille aux offic mans absurde
après chaque dispositif oui il vaut
mieux si on peut limiter les
conséquences d'un truc idiot il vaut
mieux limiter les conséquences de rio
mais ce qui est philosophiquement
absurde c'est d'augmenter les taxes pour
ensuite inventé des meilleurs
dispositifs possibles confiance pour
qu'on formule et de fax et via certaines
c'est franchement dire aux gens mais je
préfère taxer la voiture que le travail
ça c'est un truc c'est comme un
aveuglement un vrai sens et si les gens
ne prennent pas leur voiture tous les
matins pour faire vos l'on s'amusait à
ce rôle une polémique mise à part vous
dites c'est absurde d'augmenter les
taxes et après de mettre un mécanisme de
compensation
on ne peut pas on ne pouvait pas et on
ne peut pas augmenter les taxes pour une
partie seulement des français
on était obligés d'avoir une mesure
respectives du respectueuse du principe
d'égalité dans l'oil d'augmenter pour
tous après si on considère que pour un
groupe de gens particulièrement
difficulté déjà si on considère que des
cépages juste terminée par rapport à
l'objection à son raisonnement et sans
polémique c'est assez rare c'est moi en
tout cas est chez vous toujours
si donc après on veut pour certaines
personnes pour laquelle l'automobile est
un moyen de transport absolument
indispensable leur prendre des mesures
d' aide spécifique c'est pas forcément
complètement absurde c'est de me dire
pourquoi parce que quand vous allez vous
situez ou juste un tout petit peu au
dessus de la tranche pour laquelle vous
allez avoir droit et que quand même ça
va amputer votre budget parce que vous
êtes classe moyenne
donc à la fin les pigeons de l'histoire
à chaque fois c'est la masse de classe
moyenne c'est à dire qu'on va aider ceux
qui sont tout en bas qui sont déjà aidés
et et les autres ils ont qualifié la
roma d'addition d'abord d'augmenter les
taxes pour sauver environ
l'aja ça c'est une blague et déjà une
blague parce que si moi je défends pas
le diesel mais si un truc qu'on peut pas
reprocher au diesel c'est de réchauffer
la planète peut dire que des particules
fines
donc vaut choisir donc on ne l'a
commencé à nous dire que c'était un
impératif environnemental
c'est évidemment pas ça c'est pour faire
entrer de l'argent dans les métiers dans
le but d'un état et maintenant on nous
dit on va le faire porte
sur certains et pas sur la longue faire
sur tout le monde et puis cela qui
râlent ben j'y avais pas pensé donc on
va pas l'on va pas leur faire appliquer
tout ça environnementale que là où cette
année mais ça peut avoir un objectif
environnemental que là ça peut avoir
comme ans n'a pas jusqu'à ce que je
puisse la terminer donc ce serait normal
que ça occupe toi ça peut avoir un
objectif environnemental tout en
rentrant dans les caisses de l'état il
peut y avoir comme objectif
environnemental que là où les gens n'ont
pas besoin de leur voiture par exemple
les très très nombreux plus de 3
millions de personnes qui utilisent leur
voiture pour un déplacement domicile
travail de peu de kilomètres à
l'intérieur d'une ville où il ya des
transports en commun si ça les dissuade
de prendre leur voiture ça atteint un
objectif environnemental
donc c'est pas contradictoire sur les
seuls chiffres quincy fardeau sur la
scotia converse et ralph il est vrai que
je te remercie pour compléter ce que dit
olivier pardon sur la taxe la tei cpe la
taxe sur les 37 milliards can à 7
milliards qui sont consacrés à la
transition général énergétique
non mais ce que je voulais bien c'est
qu'il ya deux façons d'être sur l'oeuvre
l'environnement il a directement en
consacrant les conflits et indirectement
à en développe en incitant à prendre moi
la voiture qu'on s'est parlé il ya un
milliard sur l'étrange le développement
des transports donc vous assurer qu'on
vous entende aussi sur la suite parce
qu'on va sur le côté aussi le mouvement
gilet jaune ce 17 novembre et tout ça
qu'est-ce que politiquement qu'est ce
que ça représente
moi je veux que ce qui me frappe surtout
dans cette itinérance parce que je
rappelle quand même con
on parle de tout ça parce
qu'effectivement emmanuel macron a
annoncé des mesures ce matin sur europe
1 mais les français en parlent beaucoup
et ils en ont parlé à maquereau ou en
tout cas ils essayent d'en parler au
cours de son itinérance en principe
mémorielle
uniquement prévu en principe à l'origine
pour me dire qu'ils n'avaient pas prévu
ou elle est conseillée
voilà la paix à l'issue de nom à l'issue
de la grande guerre
bon très bien oui oui oui absolument
absolument moi ce qu'il ya déjà quelque
chose que je ne comprends pas c'est
cette manière de brouiller tous les
messages à chaque fois et là ça
recommence c'est à dire qu' il y avait
cette itinérance prévu qui est et on l'a
bien compris aussi pour sa campagne
européenne et pour développer l'idée de
la paix et en quoi la paix est un
argument qui devrait toujours aussi
fonctionner parce que l'europe est en
crise aujourd'hui est que et que ça peut
être dangereux et en même temps il
il se sert de cette ignorance à la fois
pour se réconcilier avec les élus locaux
moyennant quoi hier
hier ils étaient dans pardon je ne sais
plus quel village et page je crois est
en fait il s'est enfermé pendant une
heure ou une heure et demie avec des
élus locaux et les habitants qui
l'attendait ne l'ont pas vu et est très
florissant la grappe et après me je sais
assez les seelandais il ya quand même
une règle quand on veut communiquer il
faut envoyer un message et là il y en a
trois en même temps il ya la paix les
européennes il ya le pouvoir d'achat
vous êtes pressé puissance 10 1 dont le
dans le maquereau baczyk vous écrasez
nom est ce que oui et ils ont comparé ce
que c'est que ce jupitérien faveur des
locaux comptent les élus locaux qu'est
ce que c'est
il a reproché
non pas du tout j'ai dit pas du tout ce
que tu nous apportes de faire les tout
en même temps et que la réconcialiation
avec les élus locaux il a tout à fait
raison avant de la faire bah oui je vais
pouvoir mais chez les carburants bons
mais ils ont estimé par mouillé tous les
messages passent quant aux français de
caen des français qu'ils rencontrent pas
ce qu'il fait il fait un bain de foule
c'est mal ou c'est bien d'aller faire un
bain de foule c'est pas forcément mal
ses plans quelqu'un d'interpol sur les
carburants il va lui réponds d'aller
vous faire voir juste eu la coupe on
parlait d'ailleurs lui de l'est de la
capitale
mon message ce malien de romain les deux
capitaines les deux nés mais il n'avait
pas le choix
les deux mois là où je dis je pense
qu'il n'a pas voulu voir ce truc il le
voit trop tard il avait et donc qui
communique sur un sujet à au moment où
il est sensé nice agassi n'a pas vu un
président de la république qui décide de
faire une semaine de communication sur
guerre paix europe etc
par ailleurs il en joue pas cette
machine a prévalu tout en même temps il
commence
des cycles de faire ça et puis arrive
dans la figure que ça monte la grogne
refus sur eux
il doit se faire et pas en parler parce
qu'à ben c'est pas dans mon plan comme
je vous remets tout alors on a connu
sarko bashing
on a qu'au lieu hollande bashing est
donc maintenant alors je les attendais
attendez vous savez quand la ce que
ressentent les peuples et des français
ce que peut ressentir un peuple et la
communion qu'un peuple peut avoir avec
son président ça c'est factuel 6r que si
c'était un président très populaire et
s'il avait une hyper grande cote dans
les sondages ça se saurait c'est pas le
cas donc c'est pas du maquereau bashing
ça veut dire que les français ne sont
pas contents de la trajectoire qu'il a
emprunté et ça c'est un droit on peut
pas dire au peuple vous êtes un mauvais
peuple à partir du moment où le
président n'est pas un pré 6 1 mais si
mais si matheron bashing c'est pas macro
bachy ces réformes bashing c'est pas
content bashing parce que dans le
porte-monnaie ça va pas le chômage ne se
réduit pas le logement ça continue à ça
les sdf n'ont pas baissé et c'est rsa
le résultat fera un président aimé et
tout le monde rêve
il n'y a pas un français qui ne rêve pas
d'avoir un homme ou une femme qui demain
remet la france debout remet le plein
emploi et remet du pouvoir d'achat dans
les porte monnaie
on a l'impression que les gens font
exprès et re exprès ajouter une chose
moi je trouve ça très injuste de parler
de bashing parce que les français
d'abord et en premier et également les
médias on était quand même pendant une
année entière traits assez attentif avec
non avec un attentisme massive
bienveillance bulle sur le high
géographique ceci me maltet n'est pas
laissez moi finir mais elles suffisent
plus donc peut-être exagérément au début
mais en tout cas il ya eu comment dire
un sentiment qui était celui le combat
il faut le laisser faire il faut
attendre de voir ce que ça donne
et ça a duré quand même je veux dire ils
ont
tout le monde a soutenu la réforme de la
sncf grosso modo et c'est effectivement
depuis avant l'été d'ailleurs qu' il ya
quelque chose qui s'enrichissent parce
que il a il a lui même fait des erreurs
et des fautes et c'est quand même aussi
le rôle des journalistes de le relever
sans être forcément extrémistes ou les
acharnés je voudrais pas qu'on se trouve
réduit l'amendé sans s'est en d'abord
tout le monde à tous les droits et
ensuite les français ont bien des motifs
de mécontentement ma thèse mon point de
vue certainement exagéré il faut des
formes et partial tout ce que vous
voulez c'est que il y a toujours une
exagération médiatique il nourrit
nourrit nourri par l'obsession citoyens
nous laissez moi juste en france
exagération médiatique nourri par
l'exagération par l'obsession sondagière
et donc quand macron dès mars et aux
îles tout va bien on y va trop fort dans
l' enthousiasme pro macron et puis quand
macron est au fond du trou dans la
popularité
je trouve candidats trop systématique
est trop fort c'est tout maintenant
c'est un point de vue est bien pensé ce
que vous fournissez une transition
merveilleuse olivier pour continuer avec
emmanuel macron mais sur un sujet qu'il
a développée toujours ce matin europe 1
sur le côté la réforme ça rend
impopulaire mais je vais tenir on
l'écouté puis on en parle dit le
quotidien ne change pas assez vite
je suis d'accord avec eux mais je leur
dis aussi la voie que nous avons pris
c'est de transformer en profondeur le
pays et c'est pas simplement de traiter
les effets mais de s'attaquer aux causes
et je pense que si d'aucuns qui m'avait
précédé là où je suis allé regarder leur
cote de popularité n'aurais pas fait ce
qu'ils ont fait donc dans ces moments
qui sont marqués par l' angoisse la peur
les changements profonds il faut savoir
tenir clemenceau il ya cent ans disait
cela il faut tenir jusqu'au dernier
quart d'heure alex il faut savoir tenir
nous dit manuel macron clemenceau il en
fait trop mais sur ces quelque chose
absolument vrai dans ce qu'il dit je
pense qu'il a absolument raison de dire
que c'est quand ça va mal qu'il faut
continuer et notamment continuer les
réformes
mais ce qui me paraît terrible dans ce
qui est en train d'arriver à maquereau
comme d'autres d'ailleurs et notamment
je pense à sarkozy ce qui fait
aujourd'hui mécontentement des français
ce jeu se fait que les gens ne le
considère plus comme il le avec ce
regard bienveillant qui était real au
début en tout cas pour l'opinion c'est
parce qu'il a fait c'est pas ces
réformes que les gens lui reproche
finalement on l'a dit les retraites le
bien passées à paris et je vais nos
débats pendant mon enfant gros ça c'est
bien ça le soit du travail ça s'est bien
passé
l'éducation ce que dit blanc en
attendant de voir ce qu'il va faire
vraiment blanc caire est approuvée les
retraites si mac on va jusqu'au bout je
pense qu'il sera soutenu dans l'opinion
du cas nous figaro et je pense qu une
large fraction de l'opinion continuera
de venir on le soutient toujours là
dessus nous donc de ce point de vue les
réformes sont soutenus peut-être pas par
tout le monde évidemment une partie de
l'opinion vraiment de gauche qui ne
pouvaient pas voter pour ça mais enfin
il ya quand même plus d'une moitié de je
pense me semble-t-il du français ou en
tout cas il n'y a pas plus d'une moitié
de recettes qui désapprouvent ses
réformes
si on veut vraiment être précis donc
d'anciens hockeyeurs sujet
c'est sa façon d'être et des erreurs
c'est un sentiment qu'il donne de
relation aux gens c'est ces histoires de
stupide des sens et des maladresses de
donner le sentiment d'être méprisant
d'être loin des gens de et de pas savoir
y faire de pas savoir ne pas être de ne
pas comprendre gens-là cycle de vie
voilà c'est ça qu'on lui reproche pas
deux pas des réformes et c'est pour ça
que c'est dommage parce que moi je pense
que la réforme pour l'essentiel des
fonctions économiques plutôt dans le bon
sens mais ce soir à lausanne sauf quand
il dit je veut réformer le pays en
profondeur et je veux transformer les
choses on n'a quand même pas de
visibilité sur quel monde nous voulons
quand aujourd'hui les mâts les
ambulanciers manifeste et qu' il se
retrouve à devoir
j'allais dire
à voir ils ont une profession qui est
mise à mal parce que les hôpitaux vont
eux mêmes décider de quelle ambulances
ont choisi qu'il ya un certain nombre de
pans de la société sert que l'économie
qu'il propose à la société et dieu sait
si moi je suis une libérale je suis pas
du tout cas une gauchiste qui voudraient
le collectivisme ou des choses comme ça
mais qui nous disent c'est quoi la
vision qu'il a de la société qu'est ce
qu'il veut il veut hubé risée il veut
des start-up heures partout il veut que
tout le monde entreprennent
il veut favoriser l'apprentissage il
veut re il veut que lille veut des
métiers beaucoup plus manuels l école
ils veulent moins de bacheliers moi
j'aimerais bien qu'ils qu'on ait une
vision alors voilà que ce soit clair il
dit trop sûr parce que c'est facile
j'aurais forme mais on peut très bien
réformé dans le mauvais sens on n'a pas
dit qu'il fallait pas réformer ce pays
en a besoin
où va-t-on c'est quoi la france de
macron dans 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans voilà
moi c'est un manque de clarté manque de
visibilité aux habitants pardonnez moi
vraiment part de bois je suis absolument
d'accord avec cette critique absolument
c'est le micro comment il ne sort qu'en
top comme on dit ça on vous entend
arrahma vous continuez de parler pour
patiner c'est une balle au alors encore
le maquereau d'olivier sortir sur le
manque de visibilité et de d'accord avec
ce qui vient d'être dit
parce que voilà on ne sait pas très bien
où on va on sait pas très bien ce que
sera cette france de macron on
il est perçu et il l'avait d'ailleurs
dit que c'était un libéral est ce que
les français sont d'accord pour le
libéralisme économique j'entends pardon
dans tous les domaines avoir avoir
et effectivement si on y aller par des
exemples concrets mais comme vient d'en
citer the radio quand on y verrait
peut-être plus clair mais ça n'est pas
le camaq jeunes a su à des messieurs
macron est persuadé que l'économie
règlera un certain nombre de sujets
sociétaux qui est faux ce qui est faux
il ce qui vous a pas entendu
et si vous vous pouvez à les essayer
allez-y c'est fait toujours parler pour
s'en aller sans crainte
non mais déjà partout pour il y avait le
deuxième critique possible qu'ils
étaient franchement la comparaison avec
les morceaux il faut tenir bon ça va les
chevilles quoi je veux dire il faut
peut-être pas exagérer non entretenir
c'est l'originalité chanel iman est
ridicule et il dit que les manceaux on
vous dit c'est trop s'est jamais comme
il faut avec moi était déjà d'accord
c'est déjà énorme
alors on va écouter toujours sur ce
point plutôt lire ce que disait nicolas
sarkozy qui a donné une interview au
point cette semaine
regardez les propos vont s'afficher
aulas qu'il dit dans le fonctionnement
actuel de nos démocraties les plus
démocratiques d'empêcher de faire que de
faire les forces pour arrêter toute
forme d'initiative sont plus grandes que
celles mises au service de l'action des
patrons mire je pense que c'est
exactement la même chose par les plus
cotés je pense que de la même façon
sarkozy a été rejetée d'abord fallu ce
désamour puis ce rejet depuis deux ans
une personne si l'opinion cette
détestation
non pas tant à cause de ce qu'ils
faisaient même si bons sont d'accord à
cause de ce qu'ils l'étaient ou qui
donnait le sentiment d'être je pense que
macro est aujourd'hui victime comme
sarkozy de lui même alors vous pensez
que comme sarkozy macro est
définitivement cuit ça va je pense que
là c'est comme
bien très dur à l'impopularité asthme et
allergies alexis comment la popularité à
ce niveau à les rattraper les jours
jérôme jaffré donne demain une interview
je veux dire à ce niveau là c'est
difficile
d'accord la question c'est pas une
personne qui reste à ce niveau là c'est
facilement qu il est vrai que c'est la
vraie question c'est ça pour garder
silence est réglable
aujourd'hui ils auraient dit les gilets
jaunes des gens qui n'ont pas beaucoup
de projets pour le pays si ce n'est de
le mettre à l'arrêt voilà on se demande
qui lui dicte ses phrases mais je tenais
là les légers les jaunes je vous avais
posé la question carole parce que on
sentait une petite gêne dans la classe
politique savoir s'il faut rejoindre ou
pas ce mouvement qui est derrière
carroll oui c'est vrai que par exemple
on sent que la droite par exemple n'est
pas très très à l'aise
c'est pas c'est pas clair moi je pense
que dans ce que dit sarkozy la sueur
empêché de faire c'est plus facile que
de faire
oui ça oui bien sûr toujours toujours et
notamment de la part des partis qui ne
sont pas des partis de gouvernement
maintenant là où je pense que sarkozy à
tort c'est que emma kron d'ailleurs de
la même manière puisque il dit parfois
un peu là
cette chose là bas c'est que quand des
réformes sont bien préparés et qu'elle
apparaisse comme juste équitable etc
elle passe ce fut donc moi je ne suis
pas d'accord avec ça c'est sûr mais les
gilets jaunes les jaunes canton moi j'ai
assisté au début mais vraiment au tout
début de du lancement de cette
initiative il est suivie sur les réseaux
sociaux puisque je suis très présente
mais c'était 100% citoyens il y avait
absolument rien de politique et je pense
que c'est absolument c'est encore une
fois infantiliser les français vouloir
les récupérer vouloir politiser ensuite
il ya eu des fake lancé en disant c'est
quelque chose de l'extrême droite
extrême en fait l'extrême droite est
servi un petit peu partout pour
discréditer la moindre à dire la moindre
colère de des français et mais
finalement c'est à force de faire ça et
de ne pas reconnaître cette colère et la
rendre légitime et crédible et on pousse
les gens à devenir encore plus coléreux
et donc macro il y arrivera pas s'il
continue comme ça on va terminer là
dessus
la question du jour qui était sur les
annonces de ce matin donc sur la
compensation de la hausse du prix des
carburants et du nrj en général vous
paraissent elles suffisantes
86 % de notre répondu c'est un jour
c'est notre deuxième thème maintenant
les élections aux états unis alors pour
les résultats il faudra encore un peu
mais déjà on le sait la compagne a
montré une la campagne montre à une
amérique très divisé presque
irréconciliables des familles qui ne se
parle plus mais montrait un reportage de
notre envoyé spécial laure mandeville
alors ce débat public très violent c'est
la marque de fabrique de donald trump
une recette qu'il avait déjà appliqué
lors de l'élection 2016 et qu'il a
reprise pour l'éditeur
on le regarde cette théière lors de son
dernier meeting dans l'indiana
[Musique]
et bingo carven et vire one more time
vote démocrate au maroc et on va
regarder maintenant ce que disait lui
barack obama son prédécesseur c'était la
veille toujours dans l'indiana policiers
viennent elles vous regardez ses
attentivement sa atteint un point de
non-retour c'est le jeu normal d'une
campagne ça c'est sûr campagne normale
d'une campagne c'est le bascule dans un
monde absolument sans rapport avec celui
qui précédait dans lequel d'une part le
président des états unis décident de
transformer lui même des midterm
élections nous en référendum pour ou
contre
sa personne et sa politique ce qui est
assez imprudents parce que comme les
victimes sont rarement favorables au
pouvoir en place
s'il perd la majorité ne serait ce que
dans une des deux chambres
il aura perdu le référendum qu'il aura
fabriqué lui-même d'autre part et
surtout par une une violence et une
hystérisation du débat inwi est inouï je
veux dire mais c'est personne n'aurait
pu imaginer même encore il ya quelques
semaines qu'il aille aussi loin de dire
que d'assimiler systématiquement le plan
destin qui arrive à un criminel comment
bien de l'entendre ou de dire que si la
caravane arrivée et avait lancé des
pierres il fallait leur tirer dessus il
fallait que les soldats leur tire dessus
dans le même brésilien n'a jamais
envisagé sa réponse alexis retrouve un
peu d'air non mais c'est un peu juste
pour comparer si c'est pas c'est pas
vous personnellement c'est le concept de
brézé sur le sujet l'immigration en
france personne ne va jusqu'à dire il
faut qu'ils aient des soldats qui tirent
à vintimille quand les italiens arrivent
oh oui non mais c'est ce que lui disent
ils comme ce qui me frappe on parlait
tout à l'heure au moment de vide qui est
notre envoyé spécial états unis qui a
été longtemps correspondant qui a fait
une plongée dans l'amérique profonde
avec notamment des podcasts georges
précisé au post 4 pacifique mais tout à
fait passionnant ce qu'elle remarque en
allant parler au journal l analyse pas
le jeu les hommes politiques sont un
petit qu'elle va parler aux américains
profond et il voit le degré de
détestation de annie compris dans les
familles inoue et de pas de part et
d'autre un des grands enseignements de
son de ses papiers
c'est que la haine des programmes contre
les en titre 1 [ __ ] en titre un portrait
preuves et et dégâts l'intensité enfin
cesser ces deux parts et d'autres qui a
une espèce de fausse et qui en train de
se creuser 12 cette expression de guerre
civile quel emploi qui pose tout un
problème pour le fonctionnement des
institutions américaines parce que le
principe des institutions américaines
c'est le principe de la possibilité pour
un président et une chambre qui n'est
pas de sa majorité
finalement d'arriver à fonctionner ce
qu'invités le principe d'un régime
présidentiel c'est qu'un président une
majorité qui est absolument travailler
ensemble mais comment demain si
effectivement
j'aurais été au congrès n'est pas dans
le camp de deux genres de preuves
comment est-ce que cela il les a et les
autres pourront pourraient être arrivé à
travailler ensemble
aujourd'hui ça paraît absolument réels
sans blague or jusqu'à présent les
midterm ont toujours été des défaites
pour les présidents ou 33 fois sur 30
sur 36 je crois mais après on arrivait
toujours parce qu'on est américain et
que finalement on n'est pas d'accord sur
tout le président peut mettre son veto
sur des choses la chambre pc de leblanc
à vincennes grosso modo on avance là ça
risque d'être un blocage complet
la première partie alors c'était notre
question du jour hier sur lefigaro.fr la
première partie du mandat des de donald
trump vous parait-elle réussi nos
internautes répondez oui à aux deux
tiers
the rabbit ans et des recettes ce qui
est des extractions ce qui est
désespérant
quand on écoute trump sur l'immigration
quand on voit le brésil
quand on voit les propos qui sont tenus
mois la limite ces gens là ils existent
parce que d'autres n'auront rien fait
parce que d'autres ont échoué c'est ça
qui est dramatique et ceux qui ont
échoué aujourd'hui sont incapables de
nous expliquer comment on fait pour que
cela disparaisse
et aujourd'hui tout le monde a envie de
se met à sa fenêtre et crié à bas le
populisme le fascisme et c'est rare mais
ça fait pas un projet de société ça ne
nous protège pas ça ne nous protège pas
de d'un fascisme qui est aux portes
partout mais ce fascisme il est là
pourquoi parce que depuis des décennies
des gens qu auront des gens volent des
gens mentent et les peuples les peuples
désespéré ok on peut dire que c'est à
des mauvais peuple ils y vont parce
qu'il ya des gourous c'est la vague
c'est la vague parce qu'on n'a plus rien
à perdre
et moi j'aimerais qu'aujourd'hui au lieu
de faire des tonnes et des tonnes sur
ces types qui prennent le pouvoir et
qu'ils sont prêts à raconter les pires
énormité pour attirer les gens comment
les autres nous souffre de et ben on en
entend pas un seul
oui mais nulle part problème je suis
assez d'accord avec ce que vous venez
dire mais quand même c'est qu'on est
toujours dans un piège dans ces cas là
parce que bien entendu si ces gens là
son sont arrivés au pouvoir c'est bien
parce que parce que j'utilise
voilà ce qui le rend précédé ont échoué
mais gravement même très gravement bon
après on est un peu obligé voilà quand
on est démocrate
même si on considère par exemple
qu'obama en l'occurrence c'était hillary
clinton qui a été quand même très
mauvaise dans sa campagne qui avait bien
sûr ont représenté les élites beaucoup
plus que le peuple et donc ils ont eu
tort mais en même temps de toute façon
quand on est démocrate on est obligé et
de soutenir obama qu'elle quelques pu
être leur tort auparavant et donc on est
toujours dans une espèce d'extra ira à
saint fons et de piège infernal
rapporter ça en france la colère des
gimd gilet jaune
la colère des français c'est encore des
méchants français qui font du macumba
chine et qui sont encore pas contents et
bacon compte non non mais que je veux
dire c'est toujours le même prix c'est
toujours la faute du peuple c'est ça qui
est dangereux c'est qu'à un moment donné
ça peut pas être toujours la faute du
peuple et le peuple parfois il fait
aussi décider de choses qui sont très
dangereuses et c'est ça que la soirée
faut les arrêter quand même oui l'a26
ont eu raison dans leurs raisons mais
leur rêve mais rôti vation d'origine
aulas sur ses deux jambes c'est clair
quelques réactions sur ce sujet parce
qu'on avait un petit problème sur notre
chat mais qui est réparé apparemment
alors sur déjà sur le lac estion twitter
sur 7 sur ce thème craignez-vous que
l'amérique se déchire à l'issue des
midterms vous êtes une majorité à penser
que non 62 % estimé que ce ne sera pas
le cas
monsieur babineau nous dit sur
lefigaro.fr il y a toujours un grand
appétit des électeurs démocrates lors de
chaque vote
trump risque gros ce qui est con évoqué
tout à l'heure en disant que
généralement l'élection du terme c'est
défavorable au président en place et
poursuit
sauf que là vous allez me dire un
président terminus sur ce point un
président est censé rassembler
l'ensemble de son peuple
tron fait tout le contraire pas sûr que
ça va payer sur le long terme
s'interroge monsieur babineau quelqu'un
me disait sauf que là oui parce qu'en
fait ce qui fait c'est qu'ils ne jouent
pas les élections de midterm comme comme
le rappelait alexis brézet tout à
l'heure c'est à dire bon ben voilà on
sait très bien que c'est jamais très bon
pour le boire en place
non il fait au fond une 2nde enfin
olivier duhamel à parler de référendum
exemple on pourrait dire qu'il refait
une deuxième élection présidentielle
donc ça hystérise le débat cela dit cela
dit s'il perd il aura perdu voilà donc
ça va peut-être aussi calmé les choses
parce qu'il sera obligé de composer
justement la france elle se comporte
bien avec donald trump au sens où l alma
emmanuel macron adopter la bonne la
bonne distance olivier duhamel
c'est à dire la bonne question est ce
que aujourd'hui c'est un peu compliqué
de trouver le ton juste
ce qui est compliqué c'est que pour le
trump la france en particulier et
l'europe occidentale la partie
occidentale de l'europe n'a aucun
intérêt c'est la thèse plus ce qui est
compliqué c'est que dans la nouvelle
vision géopolitique de drogue
si content c'est l'ennemi principal la
chine
baptisé d'ailleurs par des experts près
de lui et même par le vice-président
d'ennemis c'est l'adversaire principal
à côté la russie et c'est ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant en europe c'est l'europe
orientale pour veiller à ce qu'elle
continue à être opposés à la russie
probable geste avait nous on existe
plus en tout cas négligent que comment
vous allez traiter votre allié
historique quand il décide que vous
n'avez plus aucun intérêt c'est en gros
ça la question est posée donc c'est pas
exactement très facile à résoudre et
autant ce qui est frappant c'est que de
la part de ma croûte quoi qu'on en pense
injuste dans l'analyse autant il a
décidé d'y aller deux fronts et sans
limite contre salvini ou contre orban
autant il fait absolument pas ça avec
toi absolument pas donc il ya vraiment
deux façons de traiter les autres
guillemets populiste totalement
différent probablement parce qu'il veut
essayer de ré intéresser l'amérique à
l'europe occidentale
alexis peut-être aussi que parce que
donc il ya des élections européennes et
que macron est partie prenante aux
élections européennes et que donc c'est
intéressant pense-t-il de créer ce
clivage entre les populistes et des
progressistes
d'assister là dessus pour des raisons
électorales françaises à mon avis se
trompe totalement mais ça c'est un autre
sujet et que avec les états unis la note
se son discours sur les états unis n'est
plus un discours à usage politique
intérieure tout le monde s'en fiche il
n'a pas de points à gagner donc la
logique diplomatique reprend ses droits
et quand on est présent république
française on essaie de jouer sa carte
comme on peut entre les grandes
puissances et il n'a pas de raison il
avait essayé d'abord de séduire donald
trump s'est rendu compte que comme assez
compliqué maintenant ils gardent de
distance et donc il s'en mêle pas trop
mon avis la raison de ce qu'est ce qu'il
va dire que ça en quoi ça ça ne changera
rien à la situation politique aux etats
unis
et ça ne changera rien au regard des
acteurs français si ce faire là je
rejoins ce que 10 euros 8 ans c'est trop
con condamné pour des raisons morales
des choses qui se passent très loin
auquel d'ailleurs on qu'on regarde
souvent avec nos propres lunettes sans
trop comprendre ça ne change rien à ce
qui se passe sur place de toute façon
dans ce collector briquet et savait pas
où est la france y avoir il n'est il pas
ça énerve les acteurs français de suite
de quoi il se mêle mais c'est plus un
bébé enfin une fois de plus oui puisque
c'est le diable à la bombe est pour lui
c'est intéressant de voir ce que disent
nos sondés je pense que l'opinion une
partie audio française subit finalement
ce match se traduisait pas si mal
peut-être justement parce que tout le
monde lui tape dessus ça devient
maintenant plus on tape sur les gens
plus gentil sympa finalement il est pas
si mal et puis on n'a pas parlé on sait
mais il ya l'économie aussi dit mary
schryer il trouve que l'économie mais
c'est pas ça qui fait répondre
les internautes français oui ou non ils
sonnent comme chômage et tout va que la
croissance des résultats
il peut se mettre en avant des résultats
des fouilles ans on peut trouver des
failles dans ces résultats c'est pas le
problème mais en tout cas le ja il est
proche du plein emploi extraits et ça
les gens ça fait la différence pour eux
donc
barnier nous dit aussi son élection
celle de donald trump n'était pas une
surprise compte tenu de l'opposition
vous avez fait allusion tout à l'heure
carole sur le fait que la campagne
d'hillary n'avait pas été très bonne il
ya plus il ya plus d'électeurs qui ont
volé des jambes par roger de clinton que
d'électeurs qui ont voté que d'autres
quand j'écris donc des lecteurs que vaut
le thé qtel par les trappes nous on
compense absolument que le rejet maximal
c'était john c'est à dire comme ça que
les gens beaucoup de gens enfants
la plupart des gens n'ont pas vu venir
quand mais quand on a étudié les
sondages post électoraux le vote par
rouget qui vous savez par les temps qui
courent est toujours plus fort que le
vote par adhésion
ils étaient plus forts dans les chais de
l'homme cedh et votre club
juste par la roja clinton que l'inversé
est étonnant alors on va parler un petit
peu d'asia bibi
c'était son acquittement la semaine
dernière mais elles restent emprisonnés
au pakistan ml c'est donc cette ouvrière
agricole chrétienne qui a été condamné
qui avait été condamné pour blasphème
son sort est toujours incertain le
gouvernement pakistanais a signé un
accord avec les islamistes qui lui
interdit cet accord de quitter le pays
sa famille est menacée elle demande
l'asile aux états unis ou à la
grande-bretagne même au canada alors que
peut faire la france dans ce dossier
laurent wauquiez lui veut que paris met
la pression sur islamabad
regardez la parole de la france ne peut
pas rester silencieuse
la france doit faire pression sur le
gouvernement pakistanais pour qu'elles
s'y habibi soit remise en liberté et
qu'elle puisse quitter avec sa famille
le pakistan où sa vie est en danger
anne hidalgo maire de pareilles elle
disait à la fp hier qu'elle voulait
aussi une mobilisation internationale
pour parce qu'elle craignait le pire
pour asia bibi
demain on publie une tribune dans le
figaro une tribune signée notamment du
couple badinter de luc ferry de robert &
decker et de pierre andré taguieff et
bien d'autres pour dire il faut libérer
asia bibi
il ya beaucoup de yaka fokon mai
on peut faire quelque chose olivier
duhamel seule réserve près que je ne
sais pas exactement ce que c'est qu'une
parole silencieuse dans le propos de
wauquiez qui est normalien certains
disent que vous à vous trouvez ça normal
vous vous êtes conflit vous détendre
tout en incarnant le rêve où vous ne
changez le retable font face à des
sujets la vraisemblable dans lequel on
vit on vient de passer d'appréhender
états unis qui dit que les soldats
doivent tirer sur des migrants et là on
se retrouve avec un islamo fascisme qui
dépassent l'entendement quand même dans
lequel un islamo fascistes populaire
pour condamner à mort quelqu'un qui a bu
dans un puits pour leur camp l'a
condamné à mort un gouvernement qui sen
l'appel au meurtre contre les juges omar
canton les juges de la cour suprême de
2,8 c'était totalement l'avocat obligé
de quitter le pays mais ça c'est parce
qu'ensemble ans dans la fumée quel âge
auras buteur néerlandais au pakistan qui
est
et fait l'objet de menaces de mort donc
il faut faire ce que vous faites il faut
publier des tribunes dans le figaro il
faut en parler ici il faut agiter
partout parce que quand même là ce à ce
degré de barbarie ce n'est pas possible
ce qui était quand même hallucinant
c'est que dans un pays musulman
une chrétienne dans un pays musulman qui
boit de l'eau d'un puits se retrouve à
avoir commis un acte de blasphème et
donc elle est condamnée à mort en
autriche une femme dit que le prophète
et pédophile il y à la commission
européenne des droits de l'homme qui
qualifie la cour la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme qui qui considère que
c'est un délit de blasphème
vous avez vu où on en est c'est à dire
que nous allons nos droits de l'homme
vont nous tuer parce que dans un pays
musulman ils ne font pas de quartier
c'est à dire que pour eux un chrétien
c'est un chrétien à abattre certes ce
n'est pas un pur dans un peu non mais
une manifestation populaire cirque des
millions de gens dehors pour pour la fin
pour la pauvreté il y a personne
les conditions de vie au pakistan c'est
pas c'est pas non plus une aile dorado
il ya personne qui bouge pour une pauvre
chrétienne ils sont dehors et nous les
occidentaux
un canton il ya on va mettre le délit de
blasphème mais on est d'accord alors
alexis et puis je préciserai ensuite
effectivement ce que la légion qui
fêtait la décision et mais c'est évident
que deux mais on est en rapport les deux
c'est sa montre ou en et l'occident et
où en sont d'autres alexis sur ce point
je sais pas si vous avez une vidéo
absolument effrayante qui circulent sur
sur sur twitter enfin l'internet où on
voit trop active pakistanais de 7 8 ans
tout à fait petit garçon pas bien
méchant gentil qui jouent ils jouent
avec une poupée et il s'amuse à la
pendre et la poupée sasia bibi et le jeu
des enfants c'est de pendre asia bibi
donc c'est quand même absolument
effrayant et là je le pense je veux pas
dire dire
tout ce qu'on peut faire il faut faire
peut-être que ça c'est malgré tout ça
quand même servi un petit peu parce
qu'on est d'accord il ya neuf ans quand
elle avait été condamnée y avait pas
grand monde qui s'en était mêlé est
occupé à hidalgo je dois souligner dès
le début puisque moi je me souviens
d'être allé avec à l'hôtel de ville de
paris fait citoyen d'honneur accroché
une on a fait un truc avec figures
magazine et tout ça une banderole pour
asia bibi bernard henri lévy mais
finalement à l'époque au tout début il y
avait c'est pas un sujet qui a intéressé
grand monde les chrétiens d'orient de
manière à intéresser bon été et malgré
tout il ya quand même eu du tapage et ce
tapage sans doute à fait que quand même
on l'a laissé en prison pendant neuf ans
qu'on n'a pas osé la tuer pendant neuf
ans parce qu'elle était condamnée à mort
il est il ya eu plusieurs instances qui
sont revenus revenus pour finalement
arriver à cette décision là donc je
pense que même si on a le sentiment que
c'est un peu ridicule depuis saint
germain des prés de deux d'agiter les
mains en disant liberté pour oser lui à
la fin malgré tout ça peut quand même
avoir un effet si ça pouvait avoir des
faux comme tenter le coup voilà mais
vous êtes ridicules en le faisant que
venables
sur ce sujet la france doit-elle faire
plus pour permettre la libération d'asia
bibi vous êtes 78% à dire que oui c'est
vrai beaucoup de paroles officielles
alors c'est ce que justement le silence
l'un de nous deux internautes ou dit le
silence des autorités françaises
concernant asia bibi est juste
consternant c'est de la diplomatie c'est
le pakistan c'est quoi mais le président
est dans une itinérance mémorielle où il
dit que finalement c'est l'occasion pour
lui de parler avec les français mais
puisque dans cette itinérance ils
parlent de tout et qui s'autorisent à
parler de tout et que c'est quand même
un sujet extrêmement important et
symbolique du point de vue des droits de
l'homme rien n'empêche
qu'est-ce qu'il attend pour un mot
meilleur escient
non mais c'est les séries c'est
dramatique quoi c'est moi ça m'effraie
parce que je me dis mais ce président
sur ces questions là il est quand même
extrêmement silencieux on va dire est qu
on a vu son nombre de nos responsables
politiques ministres femmes ça se
mobiliser pour autant de cause féminine
celle là le mérite au moins autant quoi
sert le faire cela dit mais poussons les
poussons dépôts sont venus sur ce sujet
toujours nos internautes sont nombreux à
agir et agir alors blueberry qu'avec la
france se moquent complètement des
chrétiens qui sont les plus massacrées
dans le monde à cause de leur religion
c'est une honte et jean qui dé lui
je suis pour la libération mais pas pour
l'accueil d'asia bibi
elle est anglophone et doit être
accueilli dans un pays où elle pourra
vivre la nature l'obsession qui y
poussent assez loin la même personne vu
personne qu'on allait pour abusivement
si maltraité s'il est anglophone pas
celle où à la tête pas le sens de la
réponse et accises homme qui manifestent
quand on voit ces terrifiants avec des
bâtons et des fins bon je me dis que
cette cette haine extrême poussé à
l'extrême pour une femme une seule femme
le monde entier devrait s'élever quoi le
monde entier la les autorités
pakistanaises ont cédé effectivement la
pression en ce qu'elle a été acquitté
elle a été agressée elle devait en
principe c'est ça qui est terrible quoi
on en restera sur ce sujet là pour ce
soir et puis merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre un merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous demain pour un
nouveau point de vue et merci à jérémy
conclu que vous à répercuter toutes vos
questions
[Musique]